[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum uh Ryan Taz is here
yes I am Ryan this is our last episode
of the year I don't know what that was
either this is our last episode of the
Year we're taking a week off for the
holidays
um happy holidays to everyone out there
happy New Year I certainly appreciate
you for listening and supporting the
show
um we keep doing this I thought this
would be over years ago Ryan I never
thought we'd be continuing this and
what's great is I promise you even
better not even better but I won't say
better but great guests in the new year
I mean I couldn't believe I got some of
these people so it's going to be a great
New Year I hope you support the podcast
if you can support us at patreon.com
inside you there's different tiers top
tiers get to ask questions they get to
the guests they get boxes from me and
notes and YouTube lives and an
occasional zoom and there's all sorts of
[ __ ] but if you if you just want to be a
uh just support the show anything else a
quarter a quarter I mean anything helps
the show let's think the price of a cup
of coffee less than the prices of a cup
of coffee and you get entertainment if
you like the show a great show today
um also a little favor
um I want to say hey
to Tim's Superman of Steel group on
Facebook
I want to say thanks
Timmy
rock on brother uh also some great at
the holidays people in need there's
obviously foodonfoot.org for uh the
homeless situation which is unbearable
uh Ronald McDonald House there's uh
Echoes of hope.org for foster youth that
I'm on the board for
um also uh what else
um
arm the animal rescue mission
saving animals saving doggies that's
what my friend Shira does and if you
want to donate
do it if you can uh if not take care of
yourself great episode today
um also a lot of great stuff on the
inside of you online store I mean
there's there's two Smallville scripts
that are signed by the end like pretty
much the entire cast it's a rarity
you'll never get these and they're mine
that I kept and giving money to charity
so there you go
so I like doing that so
um there's two there's Arctic and
veritas signed by everybody I mean
there's like eight signatures or
something on each one so check that out
be a good holiday gift and you're giving
a charity so that's nice tons of other
cool merch I can't even tell you funko
pop flash Funko Pop Lex uh small little
pictures inside you tumblers shirts
lunch boxes small little ones just tons
of great stuff for the holidays and uh
why don't we give a discount code should
we do a little discount oh oh yeah we
should we should let's do uh
let's do 10 off okay I have everything
in the store okay the the uh the code
will be
happy happy 10.
happy happy 10.
uh I think that's it and also hey
sunspin.com it's my band uh you can get
CDs and tons of merch on sunspin our new
albums out we'll be streaming in
February but you can get cool merch new
CDs uh autograph calendars all that
stuff for the holidays sunspin.com and I
believe that's it make sure you listen
to talk field the new Season's coming
out with us me Ryan and Welling uh
listen to that uh we'd love all the
support and uh it's it's fun I'm having
fun doing this and I hope you guys
continue to have fun with us right now
the socials are socials are Ryan at
inside viewpod on Twitter at insideview
podcast on Facebook and Instagram that
is correct my friend and um
yeah it's been a groovy year this is
this is a very special interview
um I'm a huge Hall notes fan uh I have
been listening to Hall and Oates since I
was young they have so many hits and and
John Oates wrote a lot of those hits and
he was wonderful I was a little star
struck I held it together I think you're
gonna really love this you're gonna
learn a lot about John Oates and how
they got along and his new album and
he's such a talented guy and I really
great guy uh super talent and great so
let's without further Ado let's get
inside of John Oates it's my point of
view you're listening you inside of you
Michael Rosenberg
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience dude I gotta tell you you look
damn good dude
well thanks I won't take my my clothes
off but thanks anyway are you sure no
I'm serious man my dad is 70. yeah you
look way younger than my dad like
everybody
yeah I know everybody tells me that
um I it you know hey I went to some
clean living and some good Italian jeans
on my mother's side so you know what
kind of clean living do you do
well where's the start I've been you
know when I was living in Colorado for
20 years I was a back country skier I
was Telemark skier a cross-country skier
biking in the summer hiking
um you know I started yoga during covid
which is one of the best things I've
ever done should have started at 30
years earlier but um you know I um I
don't drink or smoke
um and my wife keeps me on a short lease
when it comes to good food
so you know because I can go I can go in
the other direction yeah I can totally
go I can go sausage
steak very easy you know and I still do
you know but
um but you know no we we eat pretty
healthy and I I try to stay fit you know
yeah I think that's my problem is like
my diet is not great and I don't have
anyone barking at me or helping me I
just have me and my dog so I wake up and
there's no one saying hey you don't need
a Snickers bar at 10 A.M yeah and you
know what dogs like to eat
everything
that's true they do like do you have
dogs
no well we we used to have tons of
animals when we lived in Colorado but
now we lived in Nashville we we actually
don't have any pets right now so cool
working on working on working on a
little uh house dog
sweet you know I gotta tell you I've
interviewed a lot of people
I mean I you know I'm an actor and all
that but like I've interviewed
you know Odin Kirk and Judd Apatow and
you know a lot of big actors and I've
never been more excited I'm not kidding
than interviewing you
Oh I thought you were going to say and
none of them are as short as you that's
what I thought no
I know you can mess with me all you want
but I was really excited about this I've
seen you 10 times in concert uh I
remember one time you were yelling out
all right what do you want to hear to
some years ago and I go adult education
and you go did somebody say adult
education all right let's play and you
just played it impromptu and I was like
let me let me let me give you a little
insight into some stagecraft here all
right
so basically what you know and this is
what I found and I might be wrong there
might be some people who are actually
more authentic and honest than me but
um what you basically do is you know
what you want to play and you go hey man
what do you want to hear and then
regardless of what you hear you go oh
yeah out of touch man that's exactly
let's do it and that's the one you're
gonna play anyway so it doesn't make any
difference but
um there's ways around it I'm sure Bruce
doesn't do that because Bruce is so you
know he's so New Jersey cool is that uh
up here he just actually takes an actual
he's got such a repertoire and his band
knows every song he's ever written so
they just tried it out have there has
there ever been a curveball where you're
like let's play something you just
haven't played in a while and you're
actually kind of nervous about it or you
don't put yourself in those situations
um not very often you know the thing is
we have we have this really amazing
problem we have too many hits
um that's a that's a problem and and
it's a you know it's it and I say it
jokingly but um but the truth of the
matter is you know when we play shows
what we found over the years that people
just want to hear our hits that's what
they come to hear and I think in a sense
have a professional responsibility to
play them uh and in addition to that
they're good you know they sound great
yeah and they don't seem to age
um so you know we we squeeze in a couple
uh album tracks here and there during
our shows
um but basically the Hall and Oates show
is is a it's just a it's a hit after hit
after hit Extravaganza you know it's
funny because there's nothing worse I'm
glad you guys have always gotten this
right because a lot of times you go to
see bands that you love and for some
reason they don't want to play a lot of
the hits they want to tell you what
they've been up to they want to and it's
not that you don't want to hear those
but you really come the fans come for
the hits and you guys never let anyone
down that's the thing it's like hit
after hit or you know and it's it's
always a blast is it something you guys
talk about beforehand like you know hey
this is what we're gonna do it's just
how it's evolved over the years we just
realized that that's that's our show is
really I mean our songs are good you
know and they've said the test of time
they don't sound old they don't sound
tired and I mean look you could go see
Elton John you know he's going to do
basically the same thing go see Billy
Joel you're right you know I mean it's
very it's the fortunate few that have
that that kind of repertoire that can
lean on it you know I mean but the you
know the release for me is that when I
do my solo shows I do all sorts of stuff
I mean I'm all over the map I mean I'm
doing I'm doing Roots Music obscure
Blues from the 1930s you know so that's
you know I so I'm able to do that so I
don't feel like I'm constrained when I
play a Hall and Oates show I I because I
have a total you know Outlet to do
basically whatever I want so yeah yeah
and I want to get into like growing up
and get into how it all started but like
I gotta say I was just telling Sarah
your publicist pushing a rock
is a great song
thank you yes it is it is it really is a
great song it's like you know a lot
people come out with new songs all the
time they're like hey this is our new
track and I was actually I was watching
the videos listening to the song and I
was like it's catchy it's got a Groove
to it your voice sounds freaking awesome
I don't know how you still have a great
voice like this
yeah well um you know I I do a lot of
you know on my own when I'm doing my
solo shows obviously I'm I'm the lead
singer you know obviously Daryl sings
you know the way more the majority of
stuff on the whole note stuff so over
the years you know I guess I've been
lucky that I'm able to save my voice in
one sense and the other way is that with
my solo shows I sing all the time so not
only that you know since I've been to
Nashville I've developed a relationship
with a great engineer co-producer and
we've worked on my vocal we've
experimented with microphones we've
experimented with effects we've
experimented with certain techniques and
little by little we've honed in on a
really cool way to record my voice can I
play a hair of pushing a rock yeah man
Play More Than a hair it's it's so good
guys listen to this
[Music]
hang on let's rewind because we'll put
this in there
[Music]
come on I mean that's if you guys don't
all download that right now it is just
you it just grew I mean it's a driving
song It's a at home chilling song I love
it and thank you yeah man it's it's so
good and challenging channeling one of
my heroes Curtis Mayfield on that stuff
right now you could totally hear that
you could totally hear that and what I
love is that this song has a lot of
meaning to it and you know
you know you talk about mental health
and you're open with that stuff and this
is a lot of what this podcast is I mean
I have people come here and we don't
just want to talk about fluff and like
you know we want to get to know people
but you know I feel a lot of anxiety and
depression I had a dysfunctional family
and a lot of people just don't know how
to express themselves or talk I finally
got my engineer Ryan here in the therapy
and he's doing it and people really
respond to that my my fan base
especially they love hearing about
hardships I love hearing how you face
adversity and you know how you like this
song it's a rallying cry you say to
everyone who strives to overcome life's
struggles and challenges it's a
universal theme an important message for
our time writing on a cool Groove there
you go I mean I said I said that all by
myself you did you came up did it take
you a minute to be so articulate it yeah
it took me a couple weeks to come up
with that but I'm happy with it is this
one is this one of those songs where
you could feel when you were singing it
like the lyrics it just it just it was
those songs tend to be easier huh this
song has a a crazy story I mean I first
of all I have never re okay this song
was written in 2014 originally I was
doing an album called good road to
follow the theme of the album was a
collaborative album where I was going to
reach out to people I really liked and
respected and I wanted to work with them
so I mean I had Vince Gill Ryan Tedder
from One Republic uh hot shell Ray young
pop group some country people and so it
was really just a a great way to step
into other people's creative you know
worlds and see what they do and how they
do it so at the time
um I reached out to uh one of the first
people I met in Nashville years ago was
Nathan Paul Chapman who started really
started Taylor Swift off from the time
when she was a young teenager to doing
demos and up until her first uh you know
three or four albums which were huge you
know and she became a mega star Taylor
had moved on around that time and she
was using different producers and I
called Nathan and I said man I'm doing
this project and I know you're not
working so much with Taylor anymore uh
maybe we should try something and he was
like man he goes that would be amazing
because I could use like a creative you
know kind of lift and I said and I
started thinking about you know maybe he
you know what kind of struggles he might
be going through or you know and there
was things that were going on in my life
and I came up with a Greek you know like
taking a takeoff on the Greek myth of
Sisyphus you know struggling to push a
rock uphill and I thought it was a great
idea I went to Nathan's house uh in the
same little room where he cut all the
Taylor stuff and I've laid the idea on
him and he said man this is great let's
do it so we wrote the song recorded it
back on that album but I was never
really happy with it I I think I kind of
let it was kind of my fault because I
did the music and I it wasn't it wasn't
as good as the lyrics let's put it that
way and so over the years I played it
live over the years and every time I
play it I change it because I just
didn't feel comfortable with the
original version but I never locked into
the right version then during covid I
Revisited the song yet again and I
looked at the lyrics I said man this is
just as important now probably even more
more pertinent more on point and I said
man I'm going to try to come up with
some new music for this and I used about
98 of the the lyrics that are identical
to the original
um and then I rewrote the track and then
I called Nathan up and I said hey man I
got a surprise for you remember that
song we wrote back in 214 well I said I
changed it and I played it for him and
he said man this sounds great he goes
this is the way it always should have
sounded I said okay and I got the stamp
but I got stamp of approval so I went in
the studio and cut it this way I mean
how rare is that no nobody does that
it's seldom that you go back to
something you wrote seven years ago or
how many years ago and go you know what
that we just didn't get it right when we
put it out the first time let's do it
again
yeah yeah you know I have never done it
and I've always I've always felt like
personally philosophically I guess you'd
say is that
um a a recording is a is a is a time
stamp has a time stamp it's a it's a
moment in time you're capturing
something it's what you who you were at
the time what you what you were doing
the players the engineers the studio
that thing all those components that
make up on a recording
um and I never wanted to mess with that
but on this song I just something was
telling me that I had to take it to
another level yeah pushing a rock
America you find that on Spotify
everywhere right
it well if it's not everywhere I'm going
to be really pissed off
inside of you is sponsored by better
help you know this holiday season do
something for a special person in your
life you
give yourself a gift to raise your
spirits and not just for the day look
the holiday can be a really tough time
for all of us between managing family
Dynamics racing from thing to thing
braving the cold and dark weather it's
it's normal to feel down having someone
to talk about how you're feeling and
what you can do about it is truly truly
a gift I've been doing therapy for years
it's important part of my life it has
become a part of my life it's become a
part of Ryan's life and I don't know
what I'd do without it and if you're
just getting started better help is the
perfect platform that's why they've been
a sponsor for a while because they
taught they see how we talk about mental
health and mental health affects
everybody including celebrities and
directors and it just it's it's
Universal it's it's a human thing and uh
we need people to talk to someone on the
outside that knows how to deal with
these things and helps us navigate
through life so I I strongly recommend
better help and so many people so many
patrons and listeners have emailed me
messaged me about how much better help
helps them
as the world's largest therapy service
better help has matched three million
people with professionally licensed and
vetted therapists 100 online plus it's
affordable just fill out a brief
questionnaire to match with a therapist
if things aren't clicking you can easily
switch to a new therapist anytime it
couldn't be simpler no waiting rooms no
traffic no endless searching for the
right therapist learn more and save 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
inside that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash inside inside you is
brought to you by Shopify what would I
do without Shopify uh Shopify Ryan makes
simple to sell to anyone from anywhere
it's an amazing company and everyone
needs to have it whether you have a
small business whether you have a big
business when I first started I started
selling just a few things now
it's it's a business and it's so easy to
use I always look at these things I'm
like I don't want to try this because
yeah it's just it's confusing I'm gonna
need help I don't and it's a waste of
time this is one of the best things you
can get it's so easy to navigate you
could look at analytics and go oh this
t-shirt's selling really well
I sold 10 in the last week in the last
month
I'm gonna get more of these t-shirts oh
look at this no one likes this I'm not
gonna order that again or maybe I'll
lower my uh cost for that it's so easy
to use see what products are doing well
not well uh easily respond to people
buying things
um give them good customer service like
hey sorry about that we'll return it you
just press something that says refund
and
you click it and it refunds them it's
it's really it's easy it's fun to use I
go into it quite often whether your
thing is vintage tees or recipes for
ghee start selling with Shopify and join
the platform simplifying Commerce for
millions of your favorite businesses
worldwide with Shopify you'll create an
online store in your Vibe discover new
customers and grow the following that
keeps them coming back and thanks to 24
7 support and free libraries full of
educational content Shopify has got you
every step of the way it's how every
minute new sellers around the world make
their first sale with Shopify and you
will too
when you're ready to launch your thing
into the spotlight do it with Shopify
the Commerce platform backing millions
of businesses down the street and around
the globe go on try Shopify for free and
start selling anywhere once your store
is live Shopify makes getting paid
simple by instantly accepting every type
of payment do you want marketing Made
Simple Shopify removes the guesswork
thanks to built-in tools that help you
create execute and analyze your online
marketing campaigns running a successful
business means getting the insights you
need to grow wherever you are with
Shopify single dashboard you'll manage
orders shipping and payments from
anywhere this is possibility powered by
Shopify sign up for a free trial at
shopify.com inside all lowercase go to
shopify.com inside to start selling
online today
shopify.com
inside
exactly and you're are you releasing
more singles as as we go on the whole
idea is that during during covet and
from the actually the last year or so
I've been writing like a crazy person
and um I have all these new songs and I
said now I got to get them out and I
have never done a totally digital
release
um this is the first recording I've ever
done in my whole life either with Daryl
or by myself where there's no physical
product involved now not to say that
there might not be down the road but
um so I reached out to the Orchard and
there's a company a digital marketing
company called Black Box and I talked
about hey let me uh let me step into the
modern world here and and just do a
digital release and we came up with a
came up with a concept that I thought
that I had never heard about before and
they told me it's called Always On which
means you're always there like you're in
the digital Realm
on those digital dsps your music is
always there there's always something
out and you can release something every
week or every hour or whatever you want
to do
um and I said I never thought of Rick
you know I always thought in the old
school way you know you make an album
you know you got 10 songs or 11 songs
you make an album you release the album
yeah uh they said no just for keep
releasing stuff so the concept is to
release a song every month for the next
six seven months and we'll see where
that puts me and um and then if people
want it want to hear it as a collection
sure we'll make a collection out of it I
love that and you you also teamed up
with movember I read the Rolling Stone
interview which is awesome uh leading
international Men's Health charity ahead
of the nonprofits annual fall campaign
where men grow mustaches to raise
awareness and funds for men's health
issues focusing on Mental Health Suicide
Prevention and testicular and prostate
cancer I think that's badass does that
mean you're gonna grow it and then
you're gonna shave it again are you
going to keep it this time
I always liked you with a mustache I
read the Rolling Stone and I mean
it's I mean I can't grow one I it just
looks sloppy I look like a frat boy or
something like I don't know what it just
doesn't look right with me your face
fits it you have a good mustache
that's only because you see me for 40
years with the mustache
um yeah that's it you're saying if
you're facially follicly challenged so I
I don't believe it I mean I can grow it
it just doesn't look right it doesn't
stand out yours is like and by the way I
know I read a lot of the article and I
know that you're like hey you know
people you know there's a there's a you
were split on it you like the mustache
but also people would associate you like
oh the mustache the mustache and it's
funny because my friend John heater he's
Napoleon Dynamite you ever seen Napoleon
Dynamite yeah yeah sure he's one of my
best friends and I always mimic him I
always pretend you know I always just
you know and I'm like geez you're a
freaking idiot and he's like he goes are
you are you are you talking like me and
I'm like yeah I guess you're just
jealous because Lex Luthor doesn't have
a distinct voice
you know and my character didn't he just
talked like me so in a way I mean it's
like it's kind of like it's you it's
your trademark it's like people
recognize you they remember you I think
it's a cool thing I mean I'm sure you
had your ups and downs with it
what happened was
um at the end of the 80s there was lots
of changes going on for me uh you know
we had had this insane decade of Mega
pop stardom and uh my mind was changing
as a person and I I wanted to you know I
wanted to leave that guy who jumps
around the MTV videos I want to leave
him behind I was getting divorced I
didn't I wouldn't have a manager there
was some Financial issues and I just
said that the mustache seemed to to
represent that other guy that I didn't
want to be anymore and we're moving I
was moving into the 90s and I just
thought it I need to change I need to do
something new and so it was
representative of that that's when I
shaved it off and then uh let's move to
Colorado lived in the mountains for you
know 20 years and never really grew it
back uh it was a thing but now I'm I'm
more involved now I can I can handle it
I I don't have I don't have that same
connection to uh to it to me it's just
facial hair right uh when you moved to
Colorado is that when you became friends
with Hunter S Thompson
well we were yeah we were his neighbor
we were his closest neighbor I'll tell
you a very very funny story about that
um we uh when I met my my future wife we
were dating at the time you know we
weren't married yet and uh we were
getting very serious and um I um we
we're living you know I was living in my
little condo I had this little condo out
there and uh we're thinking about buying
a house and um she's she comes from a
farm she grew up on a farm in Illinois
so she's always had tons of animals and
things like that so um she found this
piece of property out in Woody Creek
which is right outside Aspen and um you
know where you had a barn and could put
you know you could have animals etc etc
so the real estate agent was a really
good friend of mine we go out there and
we're standing on the property kind of
looking around and all of a sudden we
hear these two shotgun blasts
and then all of a sudden and the little
Barn that we were standing next to had a
metal roof and all of a sudden pellets
going
all over the all over the metal roof and
I'm like what the hell's going on he
goes oh that's your neighbor that's
that's the Hunter
don't don't worry about it he's fine and
I'm like okay I said wait a second I
said we're gonna move into a house
that's literally shotgun distance from
this guy no I think he's shooting no I'm
serious I think he knew that someone was
going to buy the property and he was
putting a shot across the bow you know
seriously a meta you know metaphorically
of course
um yeah and I was like and he said no no
he's great man you don't know it won't
be a problem and so then over the years
we became friends and you know we'd go
up I'd go up there and watch Monday
Night Football with him and the sheriff
and all that and uh yeah you know he was
if he liked you he was fantastic you
know and um he um he liked being Hunter
you know he liked he liked the slouch
hat with the cigarette holder and the
motorcycle and the big glass of you know
gin or whatever he was drinking
um but you know deep down inside he was
a southern he was from Kentucky he was a
southern gentleman and uh you know we
didn't see a lot of each other but um
and I you know we we went to his funeral
the one that Johnny Depp you know put on
right where they shot his ashes out of a
cannon we were there for that wow it was
it was freaking crazy so yeah even now
we still have our house there and if you
drive out our lane you drive directly
into his driveway it just seems like
it'd be hard to talk to someone like
because they're kind of out there and
philosophical or was he more down the
Earth that you can easily carry a
conversation once you got to know him a
little bit
well you know you [ __ ] talk like this
you know guys
mumbled all the time you know it's funny
I I was asked to write this article
um uh for a magazine
in in Colorado or Aspen and what had
happened was in that little Barn that we
were thinking of buying his Red Land
Shark the one from Fear and Loathing was
in that barn and I said to the real
estate agent I said why is this guy's
car in someone else's property he goes
ah that's Hunter is it just and he had
put a padlock on the door and it wasn't
his property and he said well this is
Woody Creek this is not like other
places he goes you'll get to you'll
figure this out so when time the time
came we were going to use this little
Barn as a kind of guest house we were
going to convert it to an apartment live
there while we
um you know built the rest of the house
and so the keys were in the car so I
jump started it and I because I went to
his house knocked on his door he never
answered so I just pulled literally
pulled the car straight up in front of
his kitchen door and just left it there
and 20 years went by he never said a
word to me about it
I think he I think he just thought it
appeared you know just like appeared in
front of us
yeah no no it was great you know we um
that's cool yeah like I said we'd go up
there and watch Monday Night Football
and I got all kinds of stories okay
we'll have to talk about those sometime
because I I am interested in that now
you grew up in Pennsylvania right yeah
right outside of Philadelphia and did
you have a pretty normal upbringing were
your parents there were they cool were
you uh yeah you did you got to pre I did
I had a very very solid upbringing my
parents were together their whole lives
and
um yeah it was a it was it was a good
upbring I I have to say and I think
that's that's why it was even more
traumatic at the end of the 80s when I
went through this kind of change of life
and I had all these challenges with
divorce and all that money
um it was even more traumatic for me
because I had never experienced anything
like that I'd never experienced any kind
of turmoil or upheaval so it really hit
me hard and that's when I you know did
some therapy and started to look at
strategies on how I was going to go
forward and you know and that led me to
led me to really moving to Colorado
inside of you is brought to you by Nitza
look you're hanging out with some
friends and putting back a few drinks a
few becomes a few too many and as the
evening comes to an end and people start
to head out you think of calling for a
ride nah you live nearby you can make it
home okay it's no big deal
what are the odds you'll get pulled over
anyway
and even so what's the Worst That Could
Happen your insurance goes up you lose
your license you lose your job you total
your car you kill someone
everyone knows about the risks of
driving drunk the results are tragic and
often deadly however that still doesn't
stop everyone from getting behind the
wheel while Under the Influence that's
why police officers are out there right
now looking for impaired drivers on our
roads to save lives
so if you think you're okay to drive
after a few drinks think again play it
safe and plan ahead to get a ride it
only takes one mistake to change your
life or someone else's forever drive
sober or get pulled over
paid for by Nitza
wow and you and you went I didn't know
you you were a wrestler I Wrestled a
little too I wrestled in seventh and
eighth grade and in ninth grade it was
just too difficult the coach was too
hard so I I played something else I got
in a different sport but you were a good
wrestler you went on to to wrestle for
Temple University yeah I was um I was
pretty good we had a great the school I
went to the high school was a great
wrestling school we had number of state
champions I was a I was a
um I I won a couple Championships League
championships and uh Regional you know
District championships things like that
uh but I I wasn't that good but um it
was you know you're right wrestling's
like probably the hardest sport man you
have to starve yourself you have to be
incredibly fit and yeah there's a lot to
it um but you know what it it helped me
in good
kind of gave me some strong bones and
connective tissue could you still throw
the cross face cradle
I can do all that stuff you could still
do it but yeah but I don't know if I'd
be able to wake up the next day it's the
most exhausting sport there is a minute
wrestling feels like the end of the
world that's it you're done yeah you
know one time I think it was in the late
70s I went back to my high school
because I was really good friends with
the coach he was a mentor to me and I
went back to the high school and I made
the mistake of like trying to wrestle
with the kids
and I got my ass kicked and I it was
like I was like okay
I realized you know I'm too far out now
it's it's
yeah it hurts too much how old were you
when you were playing music when did you
get into music was that an early age I
started when I was as soon as I could
talk
um I have a recording of me singing uh
here comes Peter Cottontail at four
years old and then I have a recording of
me at about eight or nine singing uh All
Shook Up the Elvis song uh that we did
in Coney Island and one of those
recording booths you know where you put
a coin in the record from flying you
know sliding out so yeah well I was um I
always sang my parent my mom was a bit
of a stage mom she got me up in front of
people at a very early age
um
so I made my first money
um at this Jersey Shore singing Volare
in Italian when I was like you know
probably nine or ten wow
I won a talent contest I got 20 bucks
and I thought hey this is the way to do
it did this work did you did you think
back then what what age was you're like
you know what I want to do this I think
I could do this it doesn't seem like it
happened that early right that you were
like this is my career this is what I'm
gonna get into I never thought about it
I just kept doing it and I joined a
bandit you know in seventh grade was in
the same band through Junior High in
high school uh then in college uh the
band finally broke up and that's when I
met Daryl I just you know the way I
looked at it is people never really stop
clapping
so I kept doing it what you probably
told the story but do you remember the
day you met Daryl and you said something
clicked
yeah I remember exactly we were he had a
group called the temples I had a group
called The Masters we both had singles
out it was in the summer of 1967 uh in
Philadelphia there was they were both
being played on the same radio stations
so I was aware of him he was aware of me
um we were invited independently to go
to this record hop which was what DJ's
you know a teenage dance basically uh
and while we were waiting backstage
there was a gang fight and so broke out
in the in the in the crowd and so his
band and my band we went in a service
elevator down to the street and that's
how we met
um and then we just we were both going
to Temple University
um we kept seeing each other around uh
then he lost the guitar player my band
broke up too the guys got drafted to
Vietnam and I joined his group as a
guitar player that group broke up and he
and I started hanging out jeez just by
happenstance that elevator you know if
that fight didn't break out you probably
wouldn't have met that night there'd be
no Hall and Oats yeah well you know a
lot of things happened I mean if I
wouldn't have picked Temple University
you'd go to college I mean I had a bunch
of other colleges I was looking at
um you know it was just hey things you
never know how things are going to work
out who was the more outgoing of the two
you when you met were you both kind of
outgoing Ladies Man like kind of like
just having fun everything was simple
then
everything was simple then that's for
sure uh it's not the same as it is now
that's for sure uh no you know we were
hippies you know we just kind of tripped
around and did things and that
Philadelphia had this little hippie
Community downtown and we were part of
that and so you know we I was playing in
a blues band Daryl was doing some studio
work and then eventually he played an R
band uh and none of the things that we
did independently seemed to click and
then the crazy part is is that after I
graduated from college and night the
spring of 1970 I wanted to go to Europe
so I had a motorcycle and I had a few
other things I sold I got I think I had
400 bucks and I had a backpack and a
guitar and I went to Europe and and I
hitchhiked around Europe for four months
and during that time I sub let my
apartment to Daryl's sister and her
boyfriend
and so when I got back in October
um
after being gone for four months I went
to my apartment and there was padlock on
the door because they didn't pay the
rent and I had nowhere to go so Daryl
was living you know not very close a few
blocks away so I just
put my backpack and guitar back on walk
down the street knocked on his door and
said hey man your sister kind of screwed
me up here I got nowhere to live and he
said he said oh don't worry about it why
don't you just go upstairs and sleep on
the couch up there and so I went up to
the top floor where by the way where his
electric piano was and then um I slept
on the fold-out couch and he'd come up
he'd start playing piano I'd pull out my
guitar and we start next thing you know
we were writing songs and there you go
it was that easy it was that just
messing around and all of a sudden we
had known we had known each other for
three years prior to that but we hadn't
really worked together
and what did you know you had something
special or was it just two guys having a
good time no no in fact we we made a
First recording at the Temple University
Radio Studio because we could get in for
free and we did this tape of a song that
we wrote it was so bad it was horrible
what was it what was it called oh it was
hard it was some stupid
hippie dip [ __ ] so and and um
and we both looked at each other and
went let's just hang out this this is
never going to work wow because his his
voice was very high and pristine my
voice was kind of you know low and rough
and it just it sounded horrible and
little by little you know I guess I
guess I don't know what you know he he
went this way and I went this way and we
kind of figured out a way of singing
together and what was the first song
that you could go holy [ __ ] you know
this is better than that recording we
did at Temple University this is
something cool we had we had you know
the first album we did was just a
collection of stuff that
songs that I had songs that he had it
wasn't really conceived like a record
but we we got a contract so we made the
record for Atlantic Records and it was
really the second album The Abandoned
luncheonette album where it really came
together
um and that's what she's gone was on
she's gone was on that that album and
that that song was you know I call that
the perfect storm that's the perfect
creative storm but everything about that
was right was the right producer in the
right studio with the right song that we
had written with the right players
everything about it was just perfect and
um you know it's just one of those
things produced by a reef Martin one of
the world's great producers one of you
know one of the greatest producers of
all time uh but that's Bernard Purdy
playing drums one of the you know
probably one of the greatest r b
drummers of all time
um you know it's just like I said it was
The Perfect Storm it was the right
people the right circumstance and we had
written the right song and at first it
was just your guitars and singing the
song that's it well when we when we
wrote it it was um I was playing
acoustic guitar and Daryl was playing
electric piano and uh that's how we
wrote it we wrote it in about an hour
and a half you wrote that song in an
hour and a half oh yeah if if that if
that I had I had gotten stood up on a
date uh for New Year's Eve and um so
while I was sitting in the apartment by
myself
I just picked up the guitar and I
thought well she's not coming she never
got me she and I said well she's gone
and I started doing this like folky like
Cat Stevens kind of thing
um and it was like she's gone and
um I was kind of messing around with
that for a while and then the next day
uh Daryl came back to the house to the
apartment because we were sharing an
apartment and uh I played it for him and
he sat down to piano and he said oh
that's cool and he started going going
which is the piano riff that you hear
and we just wrote it and we just looked
around the apartment and I remember like
you know in the course of writing just
walking into the bathroom and then it
was toothbrush you know hanging on the
stand or whatever yeah it's all you know
frayed and you know I probably I
probably was using the same toothbrush
for four years or something but um uh
and it was just that you know just
taking these you know snapshots of Life
of loss and loneliness and just putting
it together the right way you know and
so you go back and forth like you did on
on numerous songs where you'd come up
with a little a line and you go how
about this and you just go back and
forth with like different yeah yeah
exactly
um and I you know I can't remember you
know who who came up with it but it
really doesn't matter at this point but
that that line everybody's high on
consolation
that's like I mean you think about that
line
that's a really good line yeah you know
and that was that was the kickoff once
once that line that that's the beginning
of the song was like okay we now we know
what this is about let's go and you know
we just wrote it you know what else
could have worked because I always used
to mess up the lines when I'd sing it
everybody's high on Constellation oh I
know that's what everybody thought it
was of course of course astrology
just just like yeah yeah that was well
we were hippies so you know maybe
astrology thing could have worked but
constellation's way better way better
but you know just like people think it's
kiss on my lips it's kiss on my list
it's like it's not your kiss is not not
on my lips your kiss is on the list of
the best things in life it doesn't
necessarily it is the best thing
I love that you're talking about this
because it's like stuff that I'm like I
grew up on I'm like you know how did all
this happen because I I have a band and
I had a band and we sold about 80
million uh Records less than you guys
sold
so uh that's that's a good one and I
know that it was very difficult
for me we just always I don't know any
band that hasn't gotten in fights hasn't
gotten like no this is cooler no this is
cooler and it would get some of these
fights were explosive like I'd be like
[ __ ] you get the [ __ ] out of my house
I [ __ ] don't I mean I and this was a
band that was nothing so I can't imagine
the pressures and the your guys are
making money and you're writing songs
together there's Egos and there's I I
don't know how you you lasted as long as
you did because I don't know one band I
was watching The Beatles documentary you
know and then uh one day what's his name
George Harrison just goes okay well I
think I'm gonna quit the band now
like what
yeah well
that wasn't that wasn't a good career
choice but the
thing but he did just fine George did
just fine now you know I think Daryl and
I both are very non-confrontational
people um and we would rather you know
kind of just go our separate ways and
just
let things simmer down and then figure
out a way a way around it um yeah it's
um it's you know it's it's really
amazing that we've been able to stay
together this year yeah uh and you know
we've been together for over 50 years
and I the way I look at it it's like 50
years is long enough to do almost
anything so I you know at this point now
you know we we you know if we play a
show again which we will at some point
uh great and if we don't well that's
okay too you know I yeah
it is what it is so you've learned to
like go hey there's been ups and downs
there's been all this stuff but like at
the end of the day we did something
great you know and
it's it's a miracle as far as it is it's
a miracle that we were able to create
what we created uh and to stay together
long enough and have those amazing
experiences in life and traveling around
the world and playing Live Aid and we
are the world and you know all these the
Apollo Theater and all these like kind
of you know these uh Watershed or not
Watershed but you know these these
moments these like iconic moments you
know
um and so you know what more do you want
what more do you want in life yeah did
you ever were you ever like in a not a
good place and you're both on stage and
you have to pretend you love each other
and you're like God I [ __ ] don't want
to be here neither does he yeah yeah
last week are you serious
how does that no no but what do you do
you just you have to just move on right
yeah you just you know what it's called
being a pro you know look there's plenty
of there's plenty of groups out there
that don't like each other necessarily
oh yeah okay and you know what so
whether it's you know it may be greed it
may be Professional Pride it may be
um you know maybe because you know that
you owe the next car payment you can't
figure out how to do it who knows what
the motivation is it doesn't matter
um you know I think there's a there's a
lot to be said for being a pro you know
you can just get past the other crap and
just do it yeah you know I I talked
about I deal with anxiety and stuff like
and I have some I won't mention his name
but I have a friend who he X has he's a
huge Musician musician he's played one
of the biggest bands in the world you
know him you've probably worked with him
I won't say his name
I love him to death but I say dummy how
do you do it you're in a stadium with 50
000 people and it's all your nerves
going wild don't you have anxiety goes I
take like a quarter of a Xanax before
every show that's what he does have you
done something like that did you ever
drink before you played did you ever get
yeah I well I I have never been a big
drinker I don't drink at all now
um but even when I was drinking I I
realized very quickly and actually it
was mostly what I discovered when I was
doing my solo shows if I had a drink I
was sloppier I wasn't as accurate
especially with playing my vocals were
okay but my my ability to play the
guitar was not as good so little by
little I realized that you know it's
just I'm better when I'm sober it's as
simple as that do you get anxiety have
you dealt with anxiety in your life
oh yeah well but but anxiety from
outside sources most of my anxiety I
finally realized that
you know and now that I can look back on
my life and you know with it with a you
know a little more perspective most of
my problems in fact all of my problems
and anxiety had to do with me being
trusting
and having people who I thought I could
trust not not be truthful and not be um
honest that that has been the source of
all my issues
um I try to be a nice person I try to uh
you know I try to treat people fairly I
try and I try to be as honest as I can
you know in a in a really dishonest
business
um you know if you know any gonna be
obviously you're in an entertainment
business you know it's a [ __ ] show yeah
so
um but that's where my my issues are my
issues are trusting people and having
them stab you in the back and having
them not not not be who you were hoping
they would be or at least giving you the
um you know the courtesy of uh of being
straightforward that that's that's a big
issue for me yeah I understand that it's
it's the worst business to be in when
you're looking for that because I come
from Humble origin where you know I grew
up in a small town and uh you know I
come out here and you just want to you
want to believe everybody you want to
think that everybody has your best
interest well they they all never have
your best interest it's what's for me
what how do I benefit from this person
and you know in your lifetime if you
meet a handful of people that you can
really trust and you know and know it's
unconditional the love and the you know
reciprocation you win but you have to
weed out a lot of times you have to go
through those things as you know more
than I do what was the was the hardest
time in your life really the end of the
80s sort of like fine Reinventing
yourself going through a divorce what
was it that how empty or how low did you
actually get because I know you talk
about mental health but what were how
did Desperate did you become
well I talk about it in my book you know
I I wrote I have an autobiography called
a great change of seasons and I you know
I talk about it in the book I describe
it yeah there was an issue there was an
issue with some uh money and things like
that
um and it was kind of a
I had you know and I'll I'll just say it
again I I I've been called down to a
meeting on Wall Street with uh with some
money managers who uh here again I had
been trusting for years and I found out
that um I didn't have what I thought I
had and it was kind of a wake-up call
and I remember
um you know kind of being shocked and it
was It was kind of an after hours
meeting in this big Wall Street you know
high-rise and and I remember the the
head of the firm you know this much
older guy you know he walked me out to
the elevator and he could tell I was you
know pretty shaken up and he said look
he said I know this is you know you
probably think this is you know the
worst thing that's ever happened to you
he goes but I'm going to tell you I
think it's going to be the best thing
that ever happened to and with that the
door the elevator door open I got in the
elevator and went downstairs so I got in
a cab my head up to my apartment in the
village and at the time
um I was separated from my wife we were
about to get divorced and so I gave her
all the furniture there was nothing in
the apartment except the TV hit a bed it
was very depressing but before I got
there I was in the cab and as I was
riding up Uptown toward my apartment I
started getting pains in my chest
and I thought my and I had never had a
experience anything like that you got to
remember I was in my 30s yeah and
I I went oh my God
I'm gonna have a heart attack I'm gonna
die in the back of this cap
and I said this is [ __ ] up I said
diet by myself in the back of a cab at
night in New York City and I and I got
pissed off and I said I'm never gonna
let this happen to me and I but I had
pains in my chest look a spoiler alert
uh it didn't happen
I want to let you know
um but anyway so but I went up to the
apartment and there it was this like
really depressing dark apartment with no
furniture and I'm standing there going
this is [ __ ] up I said I'm
I don't know I'm I'm doing I don't know
what I'm gonna do but it's not gonna be
this and that's when the whole thing
started that's when I started therapy
that's when I made the decision to leave
New York I sold everything I owned which
was considerable I had a lot of as they
say I might not have a lot of cash in
the back but I had a lot of [ __ ] right
you know I had apartments and a house in
Connecticut I had an airplane I had get
these car collection I sold everything
literally wholesaled everything
um and I just moved to Colorado and
started over again that's where I met my
future wife that had a house I built a
house had a kid you know blah blah blah
and that's amazing you think about that
stuff and you look back and it's like
there's nothing more important than your
health I mean they always say health is
wealth I mean in the end it's like money
and all these other things they don't
they don't matter they really don't
matter as as they make life easier of
course and they make you know but if
you're not happy with money
you're not going to be happy you know or
if you're not happy without money you're
not going to be happy with money right
if you're not happy with it
you knew what I was [ __ ] talking
about
Jesus Christ
um but everything everything got better
that's one of the best things I've heard
in a long time yeah well you know if you
hang around me long enough I put my foot
in my mouth quite frequently yeah good
um I love it do you what's more
important to you uh the Rock and Roll
Hall of Fame or rock and roll
songwriters Hall of Fame songwriters
Hall of Fame no doubt about it
um because I mean look don't get me
wrong being in Rock and Roll Hall of
Fame is a great career move it's it's
fantastic for your career right um but
if we wouldn't have written the songs we
wrote we wouldn't be in the rock and
roll right so to be and and really I I'd
like to you know I have a I'm I'm a
history buff I I love the history of
American pop music you know dating back
to the early days of radio and the
record player you know and and I you
know I'm a little bit of a self styled
you know music historian when it comes
to that and to be included in this great
you know honestly a great Pantheon of
American songwriters you know I mean
you're talking about George Gershwin
you're talking about Cole Porter the
brill building you know uh all these
amazing you know I mean I think I think
American pop music is one of the
America's greatest exports to the world
if there's no negative to it everything
about it is positive
um it's one of the few things I think
that we can ex to honestly stand behind
and say that we've never had a problem
with American pop music influencing
people around the world yeah
um and uh so you know to be a part of
that that exclusive Club is pretty heavy
duty you ever [ __ ] up on stage I mean
royally like you just butchered a song
in front of 50 000 people
no but I Pissed My Pants once and I had
black pants so it didn't matter so I got
through that you did you pissed your
pants years ago I drank I drank way too
much espresso before I went on stage and
you just saw like I can't leave so I'm
just gonna piss myself
well I I wasn't about to stop the show
it's so honest you are with that you
know it's funny I remember doing Hey
listen I am so way past all this stuff I
don't care anymore I love it I remember
uh this directory is a good friend of
mine Greg and he was directing an
episode of the show I was on and I was
like Hey listen man here's what I think
I should do he's like uh-huh uh-huh like
a dude what's the matter with you
because I I just I I go
oh my God I looked down and he had just
pissed him he wasn't wearing black jeans
he was wearing beige he had pissed
himself he's like no I go Greg you just
pissed yourself I know I have to go it
was just oh man but I've [ __ ] myself so
we don't have to get into that so we're
human we're human anyway
um what's your the one constant you look
back and say that was the most amazing
thing I've ever been a part of that one
concert the Apollo Theater with Eddie
Kendrick and David Ruffin when we
brought Eddie and David out and reprise
The Temptations uh medley uh that we you
know Daryl and I were both Temptations
fans Daryl was actually friends with the
original group
um and when I first met there one of the
first things we did was we went to New
York City and we went to the Apollo
Theater and we hung out in the dressing
room with the Temptations this was
probably 68 or 67 and we
um we sat in the front row and watched
The Temptations at the Apollo Theater
the original group with Eddie Kendrick
David Ruffin you know Paul Williams and
you know Melvin Frank and Otis Williams
um and uh
so then we were asked to reopen the
Apollo after it had been renovated
and it was a big deal to to play the
Apollo
um and so we asked Eddie and Eddie and
David if they'd come and sing those
songs with us and we were on stage we
did the steps we did the choreography
and it was like honestly it was like
tripping I I thought it was like I could
see myself from above it was like I was
not I was and you know people talk about
out of body experience it sounds all
hippie dippy and everything right
honestly it was an actual out of body
experience I I remember almost as if I
was looking at myself doing it in real
time
you know what
out of all the songs you've written I
mean Sarah smile she's gone out of touch
make my dreams I can't go for that many
or adult education uh pushing a rock all
these songs what is the one song that
you're like I I love that song more than
any other song I mean I know they're all
your babies but if there's one you had
to choose like this is
this is the psalm that I love the most
well you know I'll always say she's gone
because it's a song that put us on the
map it's a song that started our whole
career so how can you not you know
choose that one uh but I have to say and
I know you know sounds like so Shameless
self-promotion but pushing a rock is a
really beautiful important song for me
um I think I've defined myself on this
song uh as a singer as an artist it's a
producer more than any other song I've
ever done as a solo artist so it's a
it's it's extremely important to me I'm
gonna post the video too of the song
once this interview comes out like
separately because I love I love it so
much I think the song is is just super
in your vocals and the just it just it
just feels good it's such a great song
um I had no idea you wrote co-wrote one
of my favorite songs Electric Blue by
Icehouse
dude that is one of the best songs uh it
is good one it's a good one yeah
electric blue you know that song Ryan
um on my knees Tim I'm sorry I don't
have to sing it to you you know the song
You know the song yeah I'll tell you
yeah you want to hear a story about it
please you got me going now so all right
um I I met I ran into Iva Davies who's
the lead lead singer and Lead person
basically in the group ice house uh I
ran into him at a hotel uh in New York
City that we're both staying in
um and you know I knew ice house I was a
fan of the band and uh we started
talking and I was kind of in a little
bit of downtime I wasn't really working
too much at the moment and he said hey
would you ever want to come to Australia
and you know maybe we could write
something and I said oh I love Australia
let's let's do it so he brought me to
Sydney and um we you know we hung out
and we were there you know and I was
only going to be there for about you
know a week five days and we were we
were messing around and things weren't
clicking and it was kind of like yeah
you know I was getting a little nervous
because you know he brought me all the
way down there and I felt like I was you
know I wasn't delivering in a sense
um and he was just he was the beginning
of when people were just starting
windsurfing and so he was like into
windsurfing and we were both frustrated
he said ah come on let's just go to the
beach man I'll clear our heads or
whatever and he goes I'm gonna go wind
surfing you can go hang out on the beach
so yeah great so we'll go to the beach
and I don't know if you recall but back
in those days and all the beaches were
topless in in Australia
um and so I was sitting on the beach he
was out there windsurfing and I was and
so I'm sitting there and this gal comes
walking up toward me and she's topless
but she had these incredibly blue eyes I
was trying my best just to look at her
eyes at her face to keep my eyes focused
on her or her face and it just popped
into my head electric blue I went oh
okay and then when we went back to the
studio afterwards I said look I got this
idea and I said I told him he laughed
you know and I said I said let's write
up a song about this girl's eyes that
just penetrate you you know and uh and
that was it we wrote we wrote it in like
two hours that is amazing you know I was
watching the Eagles documentary and Don
Henley and Glenn Frey were talking they
were at a bar one night he goes he's
look at that girl over there man she's
trouble
she's got Lying Eyes
and that's it's amazing how a little
thing whether it's a toothbrush an
animate object whatever can just trigger
like an idea that's amazing another song
that I love is uh Las Vegas turnaround
yeah you wrote that yes I did
that's one of my favorite songs man
thanks yeah and and that song was
written was inspired by Sarah Allen who
later became Daryl's girlfriend and you
know they were together for many years
and she co-wrote a bunch of songs with
us and she's the inspiration for Sarah
smile but at the time she was a uh well
she was an airline stewardess right
um her and her girlfriend walked by I
was just sitting on the steps and uh we
started talking and um we said you know
what do you do um we're flight
attendants or stewardesses at the time
and I said what are you gonna do and one
of them said oh we're gonna do a Las
Vegas turnaround I said what's that I
never even heard it I didn't either
that's that's when you you know when you
get a plain full of people you fly out
to Las Vegas and you just load up the
plane again and turn turn around and go
back you don't spend the night and I was
like wow wow okay and so that was all I
needed to hear you can look back right
now obviously and go wow I'm proud of
what I've done look at all the [ __ ] I've
done you could actually a lot of people
it's hard for them to take a step back
and go look at this I have a beautiful
home I have a beautiful wife I have like
this music that has inspired people I
are you able to do that was a time where
it was hard to look at what you were
doing step on the outside
well I think in the in the last few
years you know um
you know moving to Nashville uh our son
went off to college
um my wife and I became empty nesters we
started to do things travel around a
little bit more taking more time off
from the touring grind you know not just
staying with that constant you know
touring grind life has changed and I
like it I have to say that it's it's a
it's a good I think I'm settling into a
good you know Rhythm uh you know at this
point I love that all right this is
called [ __ ] talking with John Oates
these are my patrons it's it's rapid
fire this is it these are my patrons who
give a lot to the podcast go to
patron.com inside of you and Rapid Fire
these are the top patrons here you go
little Lisa what is one of your favorite
memories performing on stage besides the
Temptations
be me besides pissing my pants besides
pissing your pants
[Laughter]
the buddhicon in Tokyo
um you know uh that that sort of thing
doing these firsts you know especially
early in your career that's that that's
the kind of thing that stands out to me
do you constantly I mean still to this
day get recognized every day
uh it depends on where I am and what I'm
doing you know I you know like living in
living in New York City it wasn't a big
deal because nobody cares in New York
um and then living in Aspen Colorado
with nobody seems to care either because
there's a lot of celebrities live there
now I live in Nashville and there's a
lot of celebrities live here too so it's
uh you know go to Whole Foods and no big
deal do you like it when people come up
and say oh my God can I get a picture or
you're fine with it yeah I don't mind I
don't mind as long as people are nice
you know don't interrupt your meal
yeah exactly Kelly yes I remember as a
little kid thinking the album cover for
H2O was awesome which album cover was
your favorite
well you know that is a good album cover
um that's a that was that that picture
was taken by a very famous uh fashion
photographer named hero
a Japanese fashion photograph he did a
lot of like Vogue covers and things that
was a cool album cover
um I like um you know uh geez I guess I
think the abandoned luncheonette is
probably one of my favorite album covers
is
um the girl I was dating at the time she
was an art student in Philadelphia and
she did that as a silk screen wow Patty
K do you remember singing at Naval Air
Station Willow Grove Pennsylvania I
worked security there yeah yes I do
remember that because I met the
commander from the F uh F-14 wing and he
was going to give me a ride and an F-14
which I was very excited about and it
never happened because the Iraq War
started right after Jesus Ray H if you
could only listen to One artist for the
rest of your life who would it be
oh boy that's hard
uh Joni Mitchell oh
what's your favorite Joni song
well the album Blue is one of the
greatest is the greatest album ever made
as far as I'm concerned yeah
that's a she she actually
lived right down the corner from where I
live right there I'm on Laurel Canyon
where all the you know the hippies live
and all that yeah
oh yeah there's a lot like Danny Hunting
from Three Dog Night still lives there
for example around the corner Carol King
lived up the street yeah yeah that's
classic it is classic last question
David H has there been a time that you
were just gobsmacked when you started to
play with someone
yeah but you know well when I was when I
was doing when I was doing a lot of folk
and blues
um even before I met Daryl uh or before
Daryl and I were working together
um I got to meet and play a little bit
with Doc Watson and his son Merle in the
basement of the main point Coffee House
in Philadelphia before their show uh
that was a high moment for me that was a
really that was a big deal wow dude this
has been extraordinary 21 albums sold 80
million units worldwide most successful
Duo of all time hall of fame or
songwriters Hall of Fame 10 number one
records an awesome freaking song pushing
a rock is out now you guys gotta
download it please it's you know it
won't let you down it's it's truly
amazing and what what's your handle on
Instagram so people could follow you
John it's official John Oates official
are you on Twitter as well
yeah I have no idea but I am I am uh
dude this has been extraordinary I I I
can't wait to see you whether it's Solo
or with Daryl again if you guys go on
tour this has been like a drink and true
I I couldn't thank you more than that
it'd be great to meet you one of these
days we'll try to make that happen I
would love that man take care of
yourself keep making great music and and
keep up with the mental health stuff and
keep the mustache for God's sakes
thank you so much John appreciate you
inside of you is brought to you by Nitza
did you know that driving high is
considered driving Under the Influence
that's right driving under the influence
of marijuana is against the law in every
state even in states where marijuana is
legal that means driving High could get
you a DUI and if you think Law
Enforcement Officers can't tell when
you're driving high you're wrong your
friends can tell your co-workers can
tell even your parents can tell everyone
can tell
so what makes you think that law
enforcement officers don't know when
you're driving High
driving under the influence of marijuana
can slow your response time and change
how you perceive time and speed so even
if you think you're fine to drive when
you're high you're not because the
bottom line is if you feel different you
drive different and driving high is
driving Under the Influence so remember
Drive High get a DUI paid for by Nitza
there you have it John Oates Legend I
hope you enjoyed that we don't have
musicians very often Ryan no and then
it's we should do it more often we
should do it more often I'm gonna try I
want to get Debbie Gibson on uh Paula
Abdul and I have talked oh she has a
story okay she's gonna come on the
podcast okay uh and that's really it I
just wish you guys the very best we're
going to read the top tier patrons off
those folks that give back to the
podcast the most patreon.com inside of
you and I hope you have a really good
holiday Ryan I know you're going to see
your family and it's important you know
you're close with your family they're
not too far away it's flight uh I might
drive it this time because I didn't get
the flight in time I think if some peace
and quiet you in the road a man in the
road I do I do enjoy it I've been doing
it all my life this this trip up to
Sonoma County it's uh I'm used to the
drive what's the address
um
go visit Ryan
um thanks for all the support all the
love if you are didn't listen to the
intro you should there's a lot of great
stuff in there there's a 10 off discount
for the inside of your online store
great new stuff that's going to go fast
I'm getting new space ship keys from
Smallville autographed so those will be
up again we're getting some more of
those and uh that's all I have to say
we'll be doing a stage in January but
happy Holidays happy New Year I love you
all thank you uh here are the top tiers
can do without you Nancy D Leah asked
Sarah V little Lisa you Kiko Jill e
Brian H Nico P Robert B Jason W Sophie
and Kristen K Raj C Joshua D Jennifer N
Stacy Al Jamal F Janelle B Kimberly e
Mike E Eldon suprema 99 more Santiago
amchad W Leanne P Janine R Maya P Maddie
s Belinda and Chris H David Sheila G
Brad d Ray H Tabitha T Tom and Liliana a
Talia M Betsy D to me say Betsy D
already
well I'll say it again Chad B I love her
Chad B Dan and big Stevie W Angel M
Rhiannon C Cory K deaf next and Michelle
a Jeremy C John B Brandy D Camille s
Joey M Eugene and Leah Nikki G Corey
Patricia Heather L Megan T Mel s Orlando
C Caroline R Christine s Sarah s Eric H
sh Shane RMR Andrew M zaroichi 77
Andreas and Oracle Karina n Amanda R gen
B Kevin e Stephanie K Lena 82 Jarrell
billies jam and Jay ADHD rocks Todd it
sure does luna R Cindy e Kate F Mike F
could not do this podcast without you
I hope you are safe I hope you are good
to yourself most importantly take care
of yourselves
um it's gonna be a better year every
year it's just gonna you gotta look for
the light man the light at the end of
the tunnel Ryan yeah yeah a good one the
good light don't go into the dark knight
uh all right from uh Michael rosenbum
here in the Hollywood Hills of
California
oh you're Michael Rosenbaum I am Ryan
Taylor that's right
Jesus we love you a little way to the
camera what a year what a year guys
um lots of great stuff coming up so I
hope you stick with me and I hope
they'll do this for another year at
least hey the power's in your hands
power's in your hands you could end it
whenever you want to yeah well I
couldn't
a lot of people would be unhappy I think
would you guys be unhappy probably then
don't I'll try not to you won't have to
I just have to you know make a living
yeah you guys got to get paid yeah
anyway all right love you guys I'll see
you
[Music]